[Musik]
wir sind menschen aus der mitte der
gesellschaft
menschen mit unterschiedlichsten
persönlichkeiten und qualifikationen
doch so unterschiedlich wie auch sind
haben wir doch das gleiche
[Musik]
gemeinsam für österreich
was meine kameraden und nicht verbindet
ist der wille zu helfen
so zählt zu unseren vielfältigen
aufgaben die unterstützung beim
katastrophenschutz
hier wird das wissen jedes einzelnen
eingebracht ob bei der beseitigung von
unwetterschäden oder bei hochwasser
wir sind jederzeit zur stelle
genauso wenn es um die sicherung unserer
außengrenzen geht seit jahrzehnten
leistet die miliz bei
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
einsetzen einen unverzichtbaren beitrag
[Musik]
vor allem gegen die aber auch regelmäßig
für den militärischen ernstfall
denn die release ist ein elementarer
bestandteil der militärischen
landesverteidigung
[Musik]
zur landesverteidigung zählt dabei auch
das sichern lebensnotwendiger
infrastruktur im einsatzfall betrifft
das zum beispiel die strom und
wasserversorgung
die das jägerbataillon steiermark
erzherzog johann sind stets bereit für
dich und für unser österreich
[Musik]